we have the west coast feed of hbo
stealing cable instead of trying to
randomly see nudity through the static
snow like the rest of us degenerates
big deal every time i watch that show
it's all women putting condoms and
cucumbers
that's aegist and condominist and
gourdist
oh hey dude being excited about watching
dune
too bad sheldon couldn't come with us
friendship this sucks i'm switching back
to real sex taking this long to realize
real sex is better than dune
although my research is going well i do
miss the warmth of human companionship
recording your own joke and then
laughing on said recording at your own
joke
it's like some sort of laugh track
section does the humor become half as
funny with each descending level
laughter exception oh for heaven's sake
in the mid-18th century
king rama iv of siam divided a huge
empire amongst the colonial powers of
europe in order to preserve his throne
criticizing the person who is in charge
of preparing your food that poo-poo
platter might be more literal than
sheldon means it to be
storing your pecan spin wheels anywhere
but the counter where they're easily
accessible
is an absolute sin penny is in her
bathroom and sheldon is now run from his
apartment across the hall through
penny's living room and across the
bedroom to help her
not only is this an obvious how the did
he hear in the first place in but it's
also a sin for anyone in a
thousand foot radius that has to listen
to anything happening in penny's
apartment
check out the penny burrito here she had
to have ripped the shower curtain from
the rod and barrel rolled in the bath to
get it wrapped around her just right
and all with a dislocated shoulder it's
impressive
i could call you a cab or an ambulance
no no i can't wait that long you got to
help me please
in the time it would take sheldon to
help penny get dressed and ready to go a
cab or ambulance would already be there
this is some of the bullshittiest bee
plotting to ever bull
it does seem rather ironic that for one
of 99 cent adhesive ducks we both might
die in a fiery car crash
close enough roll commercials
is this just gonna happen every time now
gentlemen great you and penny having sex
in the tent while i sit out here and
watch howard hump a cactus
oh you seem annoyed now but you're
beaming in a few minutes when you find
out there are a couple menopausal
singles in a nearby campsite that may be
desperate enough to ride your dweeb
weenie
do we be weeweep how old are they i
don't know
50 55. oh
menopause nature's birth control these
are [ __ ] geniuses in their fields of
science
[ __ ] science this joke could possibly
work if we're dealing with the
characters from encino man i mean it'd
still probably be a terrible joke and
make me want to cut my ears off but at
least it would make more sense
so what are we waiting for wait are they
truly leaving
i can believe that these two socially
awkward sexless boy men would joke about
[ __ ] strangers because they're
old and desperate and so much more
likely to cave for it
but standing up to dash into the night
to actually attempt to seduce women is
asking me to believe too much
good idea they'll be refreshed thinking
that raj's sexual partner needs to be
refreshed to withstand 14 seconds of sex
also enjoying a baked good with pot in
it i mean you can enjoy a baked good
with pot in it but it never
tastes good ever and there's no more
discussion needed on this topic
is that my arm it doesn't feel like an
arm casually touching someone's sternum
without consent
stars are pretty aren't they
up above the world so high like little
diamonds in the sky
prime time family sitcoms version of
getting high according to my driver's ed
book a side mirror is properly adjusted
once again want to point out
the cabber ambulance would already be
there to pick penny up
if i could speak the language of rabbits
i realize this is probably the a plot of
this episode or the
a adjacent plot regardless of what it is
the leonard howard and raj get high and
say stupid
portion of this episode goes on for all
the some time
i lost my virginity to my cousin jeannie
to this day i can't look at pickled
herring without being aroused and
ashamed honestly
same warp speed ahead mr spock mr spock
did not pilot the enterprise
trekkies or trackers or i don't give a
[ __ ]
how'd you see it you said you wouldn't
look sorry
as i told you the hero always peaks
peeping sheldon's
the only thing in here are blue ice
packs then what has he been digging
through in the cooler if that's all that
was left
who was your last minstrel period oh
next question
and now we know that penny's pendulum
swings from calm when friend gropes
breast without permission to
reacts wildly when asked about her
period and honestly i've never been more
confused about this character
i'll put in progress making a woman
grumpy must be on period
joke ass possible to rat
and making a tourette's joke they're
there everything's going to be fine
sheldon's here every so often i'm
reminded why anyone would watch this
show and it's simply for jim parsons and
his performance as this highly curious
character this moment is hilarious but
it's also sweet as he attempts to
comfort a friend in the only way he
knows how
fine i might watch another episode okay
our objective is the boy scout campsite
to the east not that i've ever been high
but
if i was i'm pretty sure the last thing
i would be doing is strategically
planning an all-out attack on anyone
where would the energy even come from i
feel like we're forgetting something
important
i can believe that these bozos would pop
a surprise pot cookie and fall into
drug-induced chaos i
can't believe they would miss the meteor
shower you know they all have alarm set
on their calculator watches for that
soft kitty singing skip
in the name of science if you need me to
hold your bodacious
bahama mamas or whatever the guys call
nowadays i'll do it
want to hang out with us on a live
stream we don't care if you're on the
toilet in your mom's basement or in the
broom closet just put on some deodorant
and join us during sin week 2021
march 22nd through 26th we'll release
three
extra sins videos and go live four times
to hang out with you all you have to do
is become a sin club member at
patreon.com
cinemasins do it now that way you're the
first to learn about our evil plans
and if you join today you have time to
watch over 70 exclusive videos and
podcasts
see you the week of the 22nd jerry
i want to slide my tongue around you
like a snake
two one three five five five four six
seven nine that's it just wanna leave my
number
anyway you think i was uh weird or
desperate
hello i seem to have fallen down a cliff
i've fallen and i can't get up
so is red still thinking about giving
you the car maybe even if we do get it
we're gonna need some
serious gas money because the cruiser's
a boat
i know it's about this whole gas
shortage bites
what about slim jims oh yeah
when was your last minstrel period mind
your own goddamn business gene